la visée gagner ce que vous aidiez à
c'est une bonne nouvelle non à tout
je me suis tu as une très très bonne
nouvelle tous les quatre se sont dit la
même chose ces personnages colorés et
imprévisible faisait que google avait
facile de turenne convoite ont paralysé
chose commune
oui parce qu'il a un assez proéminent
prénom est assez au jour de ce nom à
jamais sonné par un maul c'est au dessus
moi je passais beaucoup de son attitude
sur une espèce de par contre je peux ce
cadre si vous allez à cet îlot saint
denis ou dans les certaines régions où
on veut parler de problèmes beaucoup
plus terre à terre
cette attitude lovato si le visage pour
ce qui est des georges aussi de dessiner
un gag qui qu'elle est moche relevé que
tu quand vous sur les mains qui est
réparé son charme et ça vous change un
petit peu faux je pense
l'éloquence et quelque chose qui commet
des mouvements c'est un petit trou point
du tout au point de vue contenu moi
j'aime beaucoup travailler en fonction
des idées sur les concepts sur les
débats qui lui vaut la porte je pense la
politique ce métier c'est rock'n roll le
genre de voir comment cette fierté l'eau
comme un bon souvenir à travers ce
qu'ils font
comme on vous aujourd'hui est ce que
vous avez prévu une caricature sur
l'idée de s'amuser dans une cour d'école
avec fuyards ok wacom deux enfants dans
une cour d'école jeudi fournis ou des
possibles par la prestance déjà que les
imaginait enfin à 5-6 heures d'une cour
d'école ça ne m'enlève un petit peu leur
le médecin qui est chef ça ça change
tout
comment il le maintenant
je le dessine beaucoup plus souvent
c'est vraiment l'fun dessinée personnage
régulièrement à presque tous les jours
une mais cinq ans dont l'hadopi devient
personnage je n'utilise jamais de photo
je vous donnez moi c'est comme un
personnage qu'on crée mon année c'est le
moteur des sentiers pu figurants il
devient il prend une place prédominante